we've been using and reviewing ipads on
youtube for over four years now
ever since the 2016 9.7 inch ipad pro
back when we were making videos for
apple insider and we've been comparing
samsung galaxy tablets to ipads
ever since we started max tag and
there's one thing
that has never changed apple's ipads
were
always a big step ahead of what samsung
had to offer
but for the last week i've been using
samsung's brand new galaxy tab
s7 and i honestly have to say that i
wasn't expecting it to be
this good so before we dig deep into why
let's talk about how samsung's previous
flagship tab s6
was worse than apple's ipad pro apple
has had 120hz pro motion technology for
the ipad pro
ever since 2017 making it feel so much
more snappy
compared to any samsung tablet then in
2018
apple completely redesigned the ipad pro
with
square edges and a flat back making it
feel
modern and much more premium compared to
samsung's tab s6
apple also added face id to the ipad pro
making it a much better solution
than the under display fingerprint
sensor on the tab s6
which honestly wasn't very convenient
and in terms of performance
the ipad pro was always more powerful
so with that said let's get into the
various ways that i can now confidently
say
that the tab s7 has finally caught up to
the ipad pro
the first major change is that they
completely redesigned the body
with squared off edges instead of
rounded ones
and a completely flat back and even
though samsung
obviously copied the modern design of
the 2018 ipad pro
going as far as to match the same 11
inch display size
i'm glad they did because it honestly
feels so much more premium
and to differentiate it just a bit the
sides now have a brushed metal finish
instead of being matte on the ipad they
also redesigned the s pen wireless
charger on the back
which i think looks really nice one
subtle difference i noticed is that the
speaker grills on the tablet seven
are machined in such a way that it aims
the sound towards the user
which is pretty clever and it seems to
be working because the speakers are
incredible just listen to this
comparison
[Music]
i'm also glad that samsung got rid of
the under display fingerprint sensor
which wasn't very reliable due to having
to get the finger placement
perfect this time samsung instead went
with a simple one built right into the
power button
which is great because you can turn on
the display and authenticate
with a single button press now one thing
i'm very glad samsung upgraded is the
display
it can now refresh at up to 120 hertz
just like the ipad pro this was the
absolute number one feature
that kept the ipad pro ahead for so many
years
and now samsung has finally cut up
apple's version
is still better because the refresh rate
automatically adjusts down to as low as
24 hertz
depending on the content you're viewing
to help save
battery life but now that samsung
finally has 120 hertz
the display feels super smooth and fluid
as you can tell from the slow motion
comparison
filmed at 120 frames per second the
other benefit that surprised me was that
samsung was able to get the latency of
their s pen
down to nine milliseconds matching the
latency of the apple pencil
on the ipad pro that was one of the
things that made the ipad pro
so great and now samsung has finally cut
up on that front as well
now the one issue that i have with
samsung adding this feature is that they
had to sacrifice
their ammo led display technology to add
120 hertz on the 11 inch model
so in terms of the display quality the
ipad pro is now beating out the samsung
in terms of the maximum brightness
the contrast quality and the color
quality as well
as you can see in this comparison now
what's interesting
is that the larger tab s7 plus gets
hertz refresh rate while maintaining the
amoled display
so it's not a hardware limitation they
just chose to leave that feature
to the larger and more expensive model
and that's actually the only difference
between the tab seven and the seven plus
everything else including the chip the
ram and the storage
is identical because of that we didn't
even bother with buying or reviewing
the more expensive tab s7 plus since we
think that most people would rather have
the smaller 11 inch size and to prove
that
we ran a poll asking people which size
they would prefer for
tablets not mentioning any specific
brand name at all
and out of 8 000 people who voted 61
said they would rather buy a smaller
size so it's a bit sad that samsung
didn't include the amoled display on the
11 inch model
but regardless of that it still looks
pretty decent
with high reflectivity being the only
downside that really stands out
now before we get into performance i
want to touch on one final design choice
that samsung actually copied from apple
and i'm so glad that they did samsung
added magnets into the body itself
just like the ipad pro has had since
2018
so now their keyboard cover attaches
magnetically
and it holds on very well just like
apple's magic keyboard case for the ipad
pro
and the ipad air 4. samsung's previous
tab s6
actually had you stick the keyboard case
onto the back of the tablet
which was really annoying and it caused
some issues with
long long-term reliability but now with
those magnets it's completely
fixed and i've got to say that i love
how the keyboard case
completely covers and protects the s-pen
with a flap built into the case
which easily opens up for convenient
access
it also has a flap for angle
adjustability with a really solid metal
hinge
and i really like the material of the
case itself because it seems
so much more resistant to scuffs and
fingerprints than apple's magic keyboard
i also like that you can actually detach
the keyboard while leaving the case on
the back
for drop protection which you can't do
on the magic keyboard
since it's built as one solid piece so
you have to lift the ipad pro
off to more conveniently use it as a
tablet and on the tab s7
you can even fold the keyboard behind
the tablet
if you don't want to completely take it
off so it's super convenient
as far as the keys themselves samsung
upgraded them with a more square shape
and they now honestly feel just a tad
bit better
than the ones on the ipad pro's magic
keyboard case
now the trackpad on the other hand isn't
that great
it uses a traditional diving board
design so it's hard to click at the top
the magic keyboards trackpad is much
better with a unique design
that's not only easier to click but you
get an
even clicking feel anywhere on the
trackpad one thing for sure is that
samsung is focusing on making the tab s7
a great
laptop replacement in terms of a couple
of design choices
including making the keyboard itself
much better but one thing you'll notice
is that the front-facing webcam is no
longer on the top
it's now on the side so when you're
using it with the keyboard case
the webcam is now perfectly centered at
the top
just like a traditional laptop the main
issue with the ipad pro is that when
you're using a keyboard case
the webcam is off to the side so it
looks very awkward
almost like you're not paying attention
to the person you're talking to
check out this webcam and microphone
comparison to see what i mean
this is the video and audio quality of
the samsung galaxy tab s7
this is the video and audio quality of
the 2020 ipad pro
this design choice makes it very clear
that samsung cares a lot about the tab
s7 being a laptop replacement which
brings us to samsung's
secret sauce dex mode it basically gives
you a traditional pc like ui
that's very familiar to windows giving
you multitasking and file management
features
that absolutely kill everything the ipad
pro has to offer
especially since the tab s7 comes with a
micro sd card slot for extra storage
dex is so good that it single handedly
makes the tab s7
a much better laptop replacement than
the ipad pro
currently is and an added bonus is that
you can get 5g
on the tab s7 which you can't currently
get on the ipad pro
so that can be great for users on the go
the last thing we need to talk about
before getting into the conclusion
is the performance so let's talk about
the snapdragon 865 plus chip
compared to last year's model it's not
that much faster
but it's still the second fastest mobile
tablet as of right now
with the ipad pro staying ahead in terms
of both processor
and graphics performance however when i
compared the gaming experience using
call of duty mobile on both
the tab s7 and the ipad pro the tab was
every bit as fast giving you an
excellent gaming experience
so the extra power of the ipad pro is
simply overkill
for the apps and games we have today so
the performance of the tab seven
is more than enough for almost everyone
and you're getting that performance for
only 650 dollars
instead of 800 with the ipad pro so
you're truly getting a lot of value
especially since the s pen is included
compared to paying 130
for the 2nd gen apple pencil and on top
of that samsung's keyboard case is only
200
compared to 300 for apple's high-end
magic keyboard
so if you want to get the full tablet
experience it's gonna cost you a
thousand
two hundred and thirty dollars on the
ipad pro
and only eight hundred and fifty bucks
on the tab
s7 saving you three hundred and eighty
dollars
now of course there's a reason why
apple's ipads are the
best selling tablets out there and
that's because of the ios app store
and class leading software support which
leads to ipads holding their value
incredibly well but if you don't really
care about the software
or if you actually prefer android then
the tabber 7 gives you way
better bang for the buck especially now
that samsung's tab seven
with keyboard case bundle is currently
on sale on amazon
for only 750 dollars and you can find a
link to that sale
down in the description below but to
finally wrap up this review
i've gotta say good job samsung because
you
absolutely killed it with your new tab
s7
if you enjoy this video go ahead and tap
the like button and click the circle
above to subscribe
for more videos like this one and if you
haven't yet seen the comparisons
to the ipad pro you can watch them right
over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one